hey guys this next clip was made
possible by news voice which is a
democratized news app created to fight
back against the filter bubbles caused
by corporate media download for free
from news voice calm slash Pakman or
click the link under this video if there
is any way to sort of explain to you how
serious the rift with some of our
longtime allies has grown and I've been
mentioning this in my election results
coverage the conflict between sort of
normal Europe and the nationalist
right-wing populist forces that we've
seen rise in the United States under
Trump and elsewhere have now gotten to
such a point that the French president
is saying there should be a real
European army created to protect Europe
against possible abandonment by allies
including the United States in the event
of military conflict there is no
possible way to overstate the
significance of one of our biggest
European allies saying that things have
changed to such a degree that Europe
must militarize together against the
possibility of conflicts where the u.s.
may not be with Europe never mind
possible conflicts against the United
States Emmanuel macron said yesterday or
the day before I believe it was that
quote we have to protect ourselves with
respect to China Russia and even the
United States of America when I see
president Trump announcing that he's
quitting a major disarmament treaty
which was formed after the 1980s euro
missile crisis that hit Europe who is
the main victim Europe and its security
peace in Europe is precarious so this
was actually interpreted two different
ways when news broke of it
one was Emmanuel macron is saying we
need a European Army in case France
needs to fight the United States I
actually don't think that's really the
right interpretation although it's it's
of course conceivable but the truth is
that the u.s. and France are both NATO
members and were supposed supposed to be
participating in in shared defense the
idea of actual military conflict between
France and the United States even under
Trump is pretty unlikely
fortunately the more sort of realistic
interpretation is that France would be
worried that in the case of certain
conflicts the United States may not
actually participate in that shared
defense and honor the commitments that
they've made or may continue to further
back out of commitments that they've
made formally it's gonna be really
interesting to see how the American
right reacts to this because the normal
reaction from the right at the
micro-level and the end the country
level is how can we criticize anybody
for being prepared to defend themselves
they will apply this to countries in
terms of building nuclear arsenals or
obtaining huge weapons from massive
video big time weapons from from the big
military industrial suppliers that we
talk about all the time they also apply
it to gun owners at the micro level will
they also apply it to Europe if your
reaction is doesn't matter we can take
Europe because we have a bigger military
you've already lost the thread you have
no concept of geopolitics you have no
concept of diplomacy you don't
understand
networked modern globalized worlds now
let's be thorough there's another
interpretation of what and more
specifically why Emmanuel macron is
saying this and it has to do with marine
lepen marine lepen is the far-right
nationalist who now is part of the
nationalist rally party and if that
doesn't sound familiar it's because she
ran against McCrone when the party was
called the National Front they've
renamed now and they are the nationalist
rally party they have moved ahead of a
Manuel macrons party for the first time
the the far-right anti-eu parties in
France now have a combined 30 percent
support up from 25 percent so thinking
is it cynical is it just realistic if
you are Emmanuel macron and you are a
centrist and you
that you are starting to lose to the
far-right nationalists in France one
thing you might say to appear tough on
the national stage and maybe head off
some of the attrition to the far-right
that you're seeing is hey you know what
let's build an army because what's more
nationalist than talking about building
armies now the far-right nationalists
may not really love the idea of it being
a European army because they are anti EU
and maybe want to see France go it alone
but but even in this case it doesn't
matter what the motivation is for
Emmanuel macron to say this and they
could be self-serving and sort of
cynical motivations the mere fact that a
centrist French leader is even willing
to say we need an army because we might
need to protect ourselves if the US
doesn't help us that in and of itself is
indicative of how far diplomatic
relations with France have fallen so
let's understand this very clearly to
sort of sum up the actual possibility of
armed conflict between France and the
United States remains extraordinarily
low the u.s. and France as I mentioned
our NATO members we are part of joint
treaties and agreements of all kinds but
merely using this as McCrone is doing as
a defense or justification for a
European army that is the monumental
change in rhetoric and thinking on this
issue that we have been predicting is
exactly what we would see as a result of
how Trump handles himself geopolitics
have changed very quickly under Donald
Trump and in ways we sort of predicted
the way this was going to happen but
it's still shocking to see the French
president say this and when when we
think about I mentioned earlier you can
build things over a long period of time
and destroy them very quickly this is
another example of that and some of
these alliances